the kremlin says that many of those
involved in protests against the jailing
of opposition politician alexei navalny
are hooligans and provocateurs
spokesperson dmitry peskov was speaking
a day after tens of thousands rallied in
cities across russia
to call for navalny's release more than
5 000 people were arrested during the
demonstrations
critics accused the police of using
excessive force
[Applause]
they were warned but they marched anyway
anti-government protesters all over
russia demanding the release of
opposition leader alexey navalny
they defied a ban by the kremlin the
response was brutal
in a show of force many were arrested
some were beaten
some hit with taser-like devices
in moscow alone thousands marched
constantly changing their route in an
attempt to evade the police
some gathered outside the prison where
alexey navalny is being held
for many of them the protests are about
more than just the opposition leader's
arrest
protesters also say they are marching
against corruption
and four more democratic freedoms in
russia
used to being told what to do being
controlled but young people are used to
organizing themselves that's why i came
here today
because i want a stake in what is
happening in my country
it's a disgrace they've stolen
everything
from us i live near
oil and gas fields and they're just
stealing at all
i have a two-year-old son and if putin
stays in power for the next 16 years as
he's planning to
then my son will grow up with him and i
don't think anything good will come of
it
moscow was still asleep sunday when
protests started in russia's far
east in siberia as dawn spread across
russia pro navalny rallies spanned
across the country's 11 time zones
but so did the forceful response by the
authorities
russia's second largest city saint
petersburg
was no exception
some call this russia's most aggressive
and fear-inducing nationwide operation
but others say the government's attempts
to overwhelm the protests
might actually fuel the flames of the
russian opposition
and the voices calling for change
let's bring in dw correspondent emily
sherwin emily a walk us through the
russian government's reaction here
well sarah we heard today as you said
from the kremlin spokesperson
who called the protesters hooligans and
provocateurs he basically said
that the police force that we saw
yesterday
was justified because you can't talk to
hooligans
and what we also have been seeing is a
bit of a crackdown
even over the past few of the past week
since the last protest that happened
last week
on opposition activists on protesters
with criminal cases being opened with
administrative
cases being opened for taking part in an
unsanctioned rally
for blocking traffic and for breaking
the rules of
gathering during a pandemic today uh
julia navalny
and navalny's alexey navain's wife was
fined for taking part in a protest that
apparently
blocked traffic so we've been seeing and
we continue to see now
a bit of a crackdown on the opposition
and on state tv uh the
reporting has basically just been um
painting these protests is small very
insignificant
and also painting the protesters as
violent
given that reaction emily uh just put
just put it into context for us how big
of a threat does this unrest do these
protests pose to vladimir putin
i think that any protests are a real
threat to the kremlin
basically street protests are the
kremlin's nightmare i would say
and these peaceful mass protests that
we've been seeing
that we saw this weekend and we saw last
weekend as well
are a particular threat because they're
not just taking place
in moscow and st petersburg which is the
normal scenario for russia
they're also spread much wider over
cities across the country
over 11 time zones you know from cities
in the far
east in vladivostok to siberia to the
urals
so that's a new and unprecedented
element to these protests and also it
seems that a lot of
new people have been coming out people
who usually don't take part in
opposition protests um a lot of the
speak people that i spoke to here in
moscow said it was their first time
last week and this week as well um
apparently around 40 percent of
protesters last week
um had never taken part in opposition
protests before
and many of the people that i spoke to
said that this is about
much much more than alexey navain they
said that this is about
corruption in the ruling elites also the
way that alexei navaini
has been treated by the prison service
by the court system
which many perceive as unfair and they
say they just want
a different russia a more democratic
russia emily just briefly what is likely
to happen to navalny
well there's a court hearing tomorrow
that could turn
his suspended sentence into real prison
time
we'll have to wait and see whether he
gets that jail time and how long
he'll be put in prison i think that most
likely the kremlin
people in the kremlin are thinking about
what to do with him especially after
these big protests they don't want to
make a martyr of him
and cause more people to take to the
streets correspondent emily sherwin with
the view from moscow thank you
you